there's Bert Kreischer hi Bert what's
going on can see you couldn't see you
how's it going man I am fantastic
welcome to this [ __ ] just sway and
Heather B we were talking about earlier
how much energy you have in the morning
yeah
and it's it's especially a weird I guess
being that you were like texting me like
1:30 in the morning B I gotta know if
I'm coming in am i coming in on the
candy you're coming in I got pretty
[ __ ] up last night you did oh yeah how
long were you at town mmm
what were you doing don't know she can
[ __ ] doctors getting [ __ ] up man it's
chasing the dragon it's New York it was
fun man on with the stand uh-huh and it
was all I ran into Judah and I haven't
seen Judah right
it's so cool coming back to New York and
like seeing guys that you you know I
guess you started with but they were
already started and he's just like JJ
big J I love big J I love hanging out
with him and Kurt and and Arie and we
just started setting around talked [ __ ]
and I was [ __ ] fun she's had a good
time you don't have that vibe out in LA
or do you do people you talk [ __ ] don't
talk [ __ ] as much out there people don't
tip Patricia's Tommy that they don't
tease each other in LA as much because
it on each other it's marijuana
is that what it cuz we got this like
free love mentality like you go to the
store and it's like big hugs from Rogen
stand-ups in town shut up Ron White's
buying drinks oh we're all gonna have a
great time and then you come out here
you're like what's up [ __ ]
absolutely so it's not an increased
sensitivity it's just everybody's just
kind of you know it's marijuana like
they just love each other
the other night we're in the green room
at the at a in the main room it's me
Maren Fitzsimmons Norma Colin Rogan and
just and there's just a different energy
I think ever not everyone's high but you
know everyone's high kinda and Joy's
being passed around and and nor
McDonald's telling the greatest [ __ ]
stories in the world and I'm just
sitting back like a fanboy I mean Rogan
sitting there just like
wide-eyed everybody's enjoying it yeah
but it but it's it's total it is
completely and totally different there's
a I don't know if it's the fact that we
can sit down you know like in New York
it was always like standing up in front
of the Boston comedy club is how I
remember hanging
I don't think the difference between the
east west coast is sitting there's
someone more to it than that
with the shares out there lilyc space
you know like the right base you can
spread out yeah yeah but where's here
everything's close what's got you in New
York doing press for my special November
11th on Showtime it's called the Machine
and and I was doing Gotham gothic was
one is [ __ ] yeah
Gotham's a different club than like
other New York clubs right Tim yeah it
feels more like a road room it's a
little it's bigger it's higher ceilings
it's a nice room so very nice room yeah
but it doesn't feel like New York it
doesn't feel like a workout room like we
like the cellar I like to work out
material and you know the stand kind of
feels like you can go down there
Gotham feels more like a refined
experience that's another big difference
between New York and LA is that we don't
have we don't have as many workout rooms
like everything's a showcase you go do
it like we did a show I was just telling
you about like half the cast of Ally
McBeal was there I know I know I don't
want to neighbor up there like the
Oscars oh my god what happened you hear
what happened last night Tina Yothers
watch it so was it after cast Ally
McBeal
how did you know who the cast of
allegheny oh that's terrible
oh my [ __ ] judge you know it's really
sad that the cast of Ally McBeal is
still hanging out to users make sure to
make sure you have a good set the grips
from [ __ ] Hardcastle and mcCormick
are in the back I know the show got
canceled years ago but we still do
Fridays right we still oh you guys are
being so New York I wouldn't die who a
sight all I could see was Jason
Alexander II feel or whatever that's all
that's all you're never worried did that
episode guys with the dancing baby yeah
who got Chuck dude who is that walking
in but that was that's [ __ ] Peter Fox
standing for Columbo she have a good set
oh look it's sweating oh yeah well
that's the guy that's the worst
celebrity sighting in history I still
get so [ __ ] excited
I would chew I do too but the cast of
Ally McBeal wouldn't do much for me
that's the thing about LA you never know
when the cast of Ally McBeal does get
her absolutely killer so funny I did a
show one time and there's this little
girl yay
at the bar she's like posting up and
hanging out and I'm like I'm not
thinking anything about it and I'm I'm
being totally normal and then someone
goes that's Dakota Fanning I'm [ __ ]
43 and I made a complete and total ass
out of myself what did you do I just was
like I owe I mean really I I was like
okay I gotta get her to say her name in
my head so that I can go oh I know who
you are I know so I was like I'm Bert
she's like I'm Dakota and I was like ah
my daughter's got a friend named Dakota
Dakota high knows to cut up hey you
Dakota vet that's a huge horrible EP
interaction yeah
how old is she she's gotta be 21 I don't
know so it's like you were just going up
and it seemed like just a guy picking
you up at a bar like hey I'm Bert no she
had been on my show and she was hanging
out with like the people after my show
Kevin I say whenever I do a show every
one wants to hang out and drink mm-hmm
and so she's in that group and then I
like I was like I only to code I know
it's the code a fan
wait a minute I wouldn't you should
addition you should have like you know
wait papers out her and you you could
have said I'm Fanning you like you said
that's my name only Fanning I know is de
colo Mackrell is that you all these
people hanging out or kind of Fanning
that you with the df' necklace did you
hang out with her
I had to get they got a private room in
the improv upstairs huh and I tried to
like move the party up there so that we
could all hang out and so I got the room
I got they got bottles of Tito's up and
it was like all perfect and then I go
down I'm like all right you guys ready
to go up and she's gone I just brought a
bunch of people on yeah they're like
Bert you're really amazing like these
are people that were in your audience
yeah there was just amar only
I'll get a private room with the crowd
after I can't think of a worse scenario
just some Tito's a private room and your
audience and then the one star you want
to talk to [ __ ] beat us you know like
you really are hands on comic man you do
this your pants oh my girl yeah you know
I'd like to get in touch with the people
and connect
you're just in way over your head let me
ask you Jim if you had a like a
celebrity interaction you had to kind of
like arrange something like that and
then you realize that the celebrity left
would you decide I gotta be a nice guy
no I said step right back excuse myself
to go to the bathroom then start a fire
in the entrance who's who of you who
would you really geek out over not a lot
of people I would yeah are you sure why
not
like what's the lowest level that you
geeked out over like the one that you're
almost embarrassed that you were like
holy [ __ ] I can't believe that I mean he
just geeked out over a Roberta Flack and
Amy Schumer show the other day yeah
never deflected like Hanukkah woman
killing me softly she's saying killing
me sorry I thought she was famous for
the seed the best right yes I met I met
Martha linseed once I put the blue why
berkos I bet she's famous for the seed
and then the eyebrows let go is one my
first almost coming I'm like now that
doesn't make sense I'm like Oh flaxseed
oil yeah Roberta Roberta Flack come uh
no seed is a good word for come yeah I
know I know I know I did I had an
interaction with uh who was the Nigerian
Nightmare Christian Okoye you remember
him yeah for the Chiefs he's uh he's
right Nigeria he's like 65 to 80 he was
a linebacker he's a [ __ ] beast
Mariza running back he was a beast so I
was on a TV show and we were all doing
pictures and everyone was getting
pictures with him and I came up and I
made like a gay joke I go hey do you
think me and you could do a picture just
me and you by ourselves with our shirts
off and everyone laughed and he didn't
get the jokes he's Nigerian and he was
like no no and so um so then we do a big
group photo like with the cast and
everyone
and and everyone starts walking away and
he grabs me by the arm ii goes let's
take our shirts off now and I went no no
no I was joking because I got you funny
man it's here the [ __ ] head right
yeah that's an obscure one yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's not the most fun I've
geeked out over a lot of people who
would you say Comic Cons I have the
Redskins best he's going to comic-con
with him cuz it's so easy to convince
him that just a cosplayer as a celebrity
and he'll ask any celebrity for a photo
I watched I watched a video of this is
an old video of cribs of your house one
time that was back at any W when he
lived at foreign when I lived a
Florentine in Cliffside Park New Jersey
no but is that it no not this [ __ ] place
the that looked like it had mold the
nice place oh the other one yeah yeah
yeah you still live in that place know
that but what was interesting to me is
you had all your uh your autograph stuff
around yeah that's kind of cool I never
I've never gotten anything so I might
that stuff up in lieu of family or or
loved ones photos yeah yeah for a long
time your place look like a museum but
it wasn't mentally a museum it's like a
museum in OP culture art [ __ ] I don't
like I just I put up stuff I like yeah
there's a lot of [ __ ] yeah a lot of it
there's a lot of it have you been
hanging up stuff cuz I saw your place my
place is still buried by different
frames I have not done that I've been
very poor with the interior stuff yeah
to listen it I was I was impressed that
your bed looked very like it didn't look
like what I thought you'd have what do
you think there's gonna be like Christ
comes yeah no no it was like it looked
like like if you spent the night at a
sorority house like it had like it was
like wrought iron it was a very teenage
girl I should have gotten rid of that
and then had lucky like white like yeah
Daisy's my [ __ ] yes boyfriend pillow
yeah it was very queer my bad but yeah
your new your you got a whole new bed
when you moved in no I took I threw the
frame out because there's not a lot of
space between my bed my window I have a
bigger bedroom but the way it's shaped
is weird so I have to get a bed frame I
want to get a bed frame it doesn't stick
out all it just goes to the edge of the
mattress and that's it I can't have one
that's longer do you think your do you
think your apartments representative of
who you are as a person
yeah it's empty
yeah chilly and empty I guess yeah I I
guess I would think mines cluttered it
has a whole bunch of wrestling [ __ ] in
it so I guess filled with garbage I
think yeah well yeah yeah no I guess
it's representative might we're just
we're redoing my house right now it's
under renovation uh-huh and and I'm I
don't know if the new hat the new look
will be representative of Who I am like
the old one was because it was just like
I mean I'd have cuz if you've done my
podcast you don't have to walk through
my house right often to get to my man
cave and you'd see the look on people's
faces they walk through your house and
go so this is where you live like it
smells like bacon there was kids toys
everywhere right it was small and then
you got this man cave is so much better
than my house of course yeah bunch of
time you guys been to my house yeah
that's [ __ ] odd that you've ever been
to my house yeah we yes you do a show
out of your house I mean people are
gonna end up coming over yeah go on a
Rogen's house with school back in the
day I never went to Rogen's house now we
did it in different locations um I've
done a podcast a bunch time it's always
been different locations back in the day
you used to do at his house and that was
like that was like I did I did one with
red van at the old studio where the ice
house I think he was desk walk north
yeah yeah yeah I did I do in that studio
that place was [ __ ] set up to be
super high and super like loser [ __ ]
yeah those mannequins over here and yeah
just weird like Christmas lights it
looked like something out of stranger
things yeah it was really a weird one
yeah that was a fun place um but yes
you're redoing your house yo - redoing a
house homeless guys were just everywhere
just why are homeless guys Hazzard I
wouldn't used when you start redoing
your houses every like it that well
first of all we put a porta potti in our
front yard so right - have I got I came
home one night and there was like a line
in my front yard like of homeless people
waiting - really yeah I was [ __ ] up I
came back from the store and I walked
out there's two guys standing in my
front yard I was like the [ __ ] the
guys like there's a line no there's not
this is my [ __ ] house you're out so
we put a big fence up Wow
yeah is that why they put fences around
the plaza village don't come and [ __ ]
and piss all over ya and [ __ ] moving
probably be confined to the port or they
see a porta potti just like all over the
inside the porta potti you don't some
[ __ ] bum [ __ ] in your porta potty not
sure
you want to know when to talk about
white privilege I started this is white
guilt
I started feeling guilty when we put a
fence up that I took away the one
opportunity that a homeless person would
have to have like a moment of [ __ ]
civilization yeah that's just the
opposite that's why I'd feel proud of
the fence that's what I would make me
feel good about the fence yeah that's
one less bum that will be feeling good
about it you really felt bad that you
weren't gonna give the bum the privilege
of the Porta Potty well I mean you know
you got life's giving you a [ __ ] dick
sandwich right and get one thing you get
you're walking on the street you gotta
take a [ __ ] you see a porta potti you're
like you know what are there a lot of
homeless people by you yeah cuz we got a
new drug dealer
you have a new drug dealer in the
neighborhood the drug-dealing
neighborhood and so then all the
homeless started and there was a big
carnival at one of the parks uh-huh so
they pushed out all the homeless people
and so they just kind of fell over to
our side of the of this 170 yeah and and
it was better like we had a your street
is like very residential and the drug
dealers dealing heroin and meth and so
they just he's literally right up the
street from us he lives with Lisa at uh
Joey Diaz his producer I lives next door
to him oh really
I told him he was the guy goes wait you
talking about Darrell oh yeah yeah
that's what he does I was wondering what
he does um but so we had a way to break
in an attempt like a homeless person try
to break into our house and then you
cannot [ __ ] scare a homeless person
like if it was like I'm sure you can't
show a job application actually
frightens them together yeah got in
comes the boys I say god these [ __ ]
these lazy homeless guys need to get up
and work for a living honey quick good
exactly we know my dog my dog went after
him her it was a her my dog went after
her and then I started yelling at her
and I had and then another guy the next
night did the same thing and so that's
and then we called the cops cops showed
up immediately
[ __ ] immediately they were there in
like three minutes just waiting to get
somebody they were like we're here like
it was amazing all the [ __ ] people talk
about cops three minutes yeah that my
daughters were freaked out so I was like
I go hey do you mind if my daughters
come out like did they get did the
homeless lady get in the house no she's
trying to get into the backyard and I
was sitting out front
gonna cigar with my dog she didn't seem
dog smokes yeah I gotta get I gotta
stick it in between her paw but uh and
so we it was crazy we used to have
chickens yes still got chickens you
didn't love many three you ever been to
his houses you got the chicken no I
happened to just stroll around his
backyard yeah why cuz my but I think
it's this thing that people now life is
so easy they want to find what hardship
was like to connect with some sort of
realness right you know I mean
everything right now is so easy like hey
Siri who's bachman-turner overdrive
right and and but so I think my wife
wanted something like growing the
tomatoes or one of those things so eat
the chickens food chicken eggs are
[ __ ] amazing
yeah okay are better than like they are
like butter there when you get those
homemade egg and sometimes they come out
with two yolks in them oh they're
[ __ ] incredible
now is he got any yolks so Jim's got a
soundboard now no yeah you better don't
you put his own sounds on the sound
Allah it really helps the show and a big
thank you very much yeah no it's super
super helpful and never out of context
yeah awesome that salute what kind of
stuff you got on yourself just important
stuff pops up it's like movie clips that
nobody's ever heard and cannot place and
sounds that he made what the [ __ ] see
how that works
ah perfect Ed Norton
no that was a [ __ ] Curb Your
Enthusiasm oh that one wasn't yours I
was Adrienne's what - shut the [ __ ] up
one give us on the soundboard no I know
I know I'm just saying that that would
that wouldn't go in the category of your
obscure movie
oh no no sound bites yeah that's one
curb that's actually something that
you've heard of him can relate to um
but you didn't unleash the chickens on
the person who broke into your backyard
no no why the cops came out and I told
the cops and say do you mind if the
girls come down and uh like my daughters
are freaked out mmm and then I was like
can you just you know talk to them in
the conflict of course my girls come
down and they had made they had gotten
lollipops and put notes on them and said
you are our heroes oh and the cops like
melted they were like listen ladies
don't
we're going to be circling the block
where you guys go to bed we won't let
anything happen is outside they just do
that or did your wife tell them to I
told I asked him I said do you mind
talking to the girls no no no no they
just did a lollipop they just did it Wow
they just did it and then as they're
doing this my oldest is tugging my arm
like okay dad let's go I was like
Georgia give him a second let him finish
she's like dad we got it okay thank you
guys thank you sir thank you sir very
much as I put the [ __ ] George and she we
start walking back she's like we are all
wearing marijuana shirts and they were
wearing shirts that you get from
dispensaries and I had one from this
company called the dope state and it
looks like the North Face but of the
marijuana we are for wearing their water
they live in finally your daughter's
came down at the cops threw you down and
arrested you violent arrest see the [ __ ]
out of me yeah probably yeah your your
your daughters seem to be have a good
self-awareness like just seem to be
aware of this situation we need to not
be here right now because we're wearing
marijuana shirts no my oldest my
youngest is oblivious she is oh [ __ ]
blue and she's still seeing ghosts no no
who knows we think she's time-traveling
now that's right that's how you tell me
about she was time-traveling yeah we're
done with time-traveling now we're just
getting trying to get her to read all
the she she's ten okay she's dyslexic I
asked fall yeah it's late in the game
it's so it's so bad way to be
encouraging Sam it is it's lighten again
wait dislikes is the other tricks that
they can do to kind of read better is I
would I asked it was didi sick yeah no
you got to get evil there's a font that
and remember when we met Henry Fonda
this is a long time ago yes on the set
of all the Oxbow incident no you mean
Henry Winkler I think oh yeah yeah I
think Henry Winkler a member I met Henry
Fonda yeah [ __ ] my pants he was he was
selling a book and I didn't pay
attention to it Hank's sizzler is that
the name of the character I don't
remember what the name is Gibson senator
yeah and it's written in a dyslexia font
so that you can read better in that font
so we got the font for my daughter and
really helped like really just Roman
numerals no I don't know it's it's a
dyslexia font and it helps with dyslexia
is that what it looks like it's kind of
like is that the dyslexia font I think
so it's called dyslexia yeah and it's
just like it's pretty standard except it
looks like it's written kind of like
there's some there's weird curves and
stuff to it and that helps dyslexia well
what happened what's interesting is we
went to one we had to go to an IEP for
her IEP it's I don't know I think it's a
something for I don't know it's like a
helper okay or whatever all right like
the people that really like focus on her
specifically sure right and so you'd
like
not one [ __ ] person that simply say
note from before yeah that was in the
fog or as I sum up this room for yeah so
we went to this thing this IP and I'd
[ __ ] up I was came in firing a little
hot mm-hmm but I said what's that mean
fire no hot well I had I partied with
Joey Diaz the night before and that was
I still felt the effects that morning
right and then I brought two diet cokes
thinking I that would wake me up and
turned out I brought two Coors lights
again
seriously seriously that's seriously you
got no oh you know what's so funny I got
a lot why no tell when I drank I puke oh
no no no no I'm not that kind of a
drinker like if I don't if I if I feel
like I'm sick I just don't drink okay
yeah oh did you drink the Coors light's
you just look at her like Oh murder you
did murder them and so yeah I have to
[ __ ] Coors lights on a campus right
yeah what am I gonna write I don't
already open one yeah thinking it's a
diet coke you gotta get rid of him yeah
murdered it so uh ten we're sitting at
this IEP I'm a little loose in their
head and they're like you know she's
having a really hard time reading and
it's really holding her back we're
wondering you know if we're gonna move
around a fifth grade and I'm like can we
just teach your Braille and they're like
what I go her eyes don't [ __ ] work
like let's just pretend her eyes don't
work let's just say she didn't have eyes
right when we go how would we approach
it from that and they're like whoa I go
over to do with a blind student they're
like we give her audio books
we give her audiobooks and they're like
yeah it seems so simple it's like are
you [ __ ] kidding me yeah this kids
getting her ass handed to her every
single day
and no one thought to give her a [ __ ]
audiobook she's just amazing to have
that though yeah of course yeah yeah
they're all your books for everything
and so she started listening audiobooks
and it was like and now everything's
fine yeah but now it's like the stuff
you know the teacher will say would go
home read chapters three and four now
she just goes in [ __ ] listens to him
yeah but yeah so we got tutors out to
ask for like it's it's we're taking my
wife's not one of those people that if
there's an issue she deals with it right
like if you if she feels a lump you're
going to the doctor I'm if I'm feeling
lump I just call Duncan Trussell and go
hey what do you think I said yeah why
so what I said will she be able to read
comfortably or no no probably never Wow
but Joyce audience I see you uh what's
her severe dyslexia yeah yeah yeah and
there's I don't know there's different
levels of it like she I have a joke
about it that I tell him I special not
like a joke joke but like you literally
watch her you watch her look at a word
and then like like if we were reading
together she does this like and tries to
guess it off your face like before you
say it
she'll be like ah chance you know what
g-get jerk Johnny no it's Jim Norton
okay Jim Norton you look here you sees
you kind of pronouncing the first
syllable or whatever it's I mean it's
it's like it's intense
but you know what it's like everyone's
got the [ __ ] problems that's her
[ __ ] problem right it's like there's
worse there's much worse we're thinking
about Senator a different school and we
went there I'm like I she's not those
folks please she'll be fine nobody
[ __ ] reads anymore anyway no [ __ ] -
yeah yeah I guess watch YouTube every
everything that you want to learn is
there's an instructional video on
YouTube that's what people can do voice
activation for stuff you don't have to
like yeah i but as much I told her that
I'm only thinking of Syria I thought
that's true and I know the walks of life
and my help and Google assistant no you
have hit f @ FN 4 on your computer and
you can just talk your your paper Greg
Fitzsimmons wrote his entire book we
Dragon Dictate really just read it in
1989 who the [ __ ] uses dragon anymore is
that the popular that's what a fan works
on your computer FM for and you're just
talking into your computer I know
either yeah that's all I do it's talking
so like you have to hold them down while
you're talking no no you hit FM for when
it comes up and it's like you see a
little box really inconvenient to just
hold the button the hole yeah no I die I
when I reply the emails I'll tell you
what cuz I have whatever issues she has
I got some oh also hallo dyslexic yeah
when if you one of the funniest things
I've ever done in my career is my
audiobook because I wrote a book and
then I had to read the audiobook and I
could not it took me 15 hours to read a
five-hour book oh and it was and they
left it all in they left me going mother
that's good and so uh and it like I fall
apart laughing one poem I'm taking off
my [ __ ] pants I'm so uncomfortable
this [ __ ] room this sucks
so it's all in that's all in and then I
and I did I wrote a chapter about
Patrice so and I did his voice hey Bert
what I was a horrible how long is the
audiobook then five hours so but they
said that ad they cut it down if they
left it all like they all those they put
in just cut out some other [ __ ] yeah
just anything that was working they
didn't they took out perfect and it's
just all me losing my [ __ ] mind
that's perfect but uh I don't know what
I was gonna say about that
but yeah I have our time reading I've
worked on me but what I do is for emails
is this is something my wife did figure
it out for me is when you get sent
emails on your thing open them up so
they're a separate thing and then put
them all over your screen and then go
through them one by one so I put hit fm4
and just reply to all my emails like
that it's so much easier to put them all
on your screen so like I get on my
computer and then ever I go through my
email and then I double click on them so
they open up in a separate window uh-huh
and then I open all the emails I have to
reply to so you get like 12 emails
opened up and then you just go through
it one by one with fm4 and you're like
yes how do you read him I can't I mean
even read I'm not my [ __ ] [ __ ]
honey the e is [ __ ] Leroy from Fame
but if you can't write how could you
know I'm it's just easier I'm just I can
also type it but I just decided put your
feet better game abhors my thing that
hey Siri is [ __ ] amazing yeah I just
love it Siri on the phone when you go
hey Siri
I know set an alarm for 10:00 a.m.
tomorrow
all you have to say hey Siri I never
address it as Siri
Jimmy she's already here hey Siri I'm
sorry what is well look Jimmy hey Siri
it's just it's just seven alarm for 10
a.m. hey Siri you don't exactly have you
unconscious looking at me you don't have
the new operating system no I don't I'd
be great if she goes hey Jimmy yeah you
don't have the new iPhone no I don't get
the update the update has it no matter
what the update the update is doesn't
work turns your phone into a piece of
[ __ ] if you don't have a new one really
really well you guys should drop your
phones more often I don't like the new
Siri because it used to be like Hayes
now it's voice recognized but I used to
be able if you said hey Siri on the
radio it would like all the listeners
would get all [ __ ] pissed off because
you turn on everybody series I did that
at Philadelphia yeah hey guys I'm gonna
put their phones on the table I go hey
Siri set a reminder for November 11th at
10 p.m. to watch my Showtime special she
just did it what did she say alright
cornice and oh you have the hit any both
phones we're setting reminders [ __ ]
amazing
yeah get them what would a reminder do
what say anything like oh I'm gonna come
you could have just said that I know but
I like to press it I want to show off
don't forget it surprised it's not a tap
push I still I'm just getting used to
all this I'm so excited you have a sound
wait I am just one of those things that
I think I'll [ __ ] really enjoy
listening to yeah yeah I'm working on
I'm getting used to those things as like
as a comment doing the road we would
have mocked with like in 1997 yeah or in
2001 but now like if you gave me a sound
board I'd be like [ __ ] yes yeah awesome
like one of my friend my remember I
think I I think I emailed you and asked
you if you can help me get it is I love
more than anything when they do the
Friday chant and play Loverboy's working
for the weekend who his radio stations
in generation oh yeah yeah how head do
it all the time Khalid every Friday and
I try to trick him into saying the word
Friday I'll go amen what was that movie
ice Cuban and Cuba Gooding jr. in he's
like what he's like
cuba cuba gooding jr. with a the pot he
goes no no no you're taking a Chris
Tucker and it's Friday and on what was
it for teddy Friday it's my favorite I
didn't know how do you compartmentalize
doing stand-up in the city when it's a
shorter set like ten minutes versus
working out hours I just work on a
15-minute set I get the cellar I just go
up and I'll start just talking and
whatever like eventually I have a new 15
and I'll just plop that into the [ __ ]
set I'll usually it's still fun and
fresh you know you know you're not you
would not do anything from the past that
already worked
you are always not oh yeah no no I mean
I do but once I shoot it I try not to no
I mean no I meant I meant when you're on
the in the cellar it's just strictly
figuring out brand-new material like
well I mean brand new within this times
I do stuff that I'm still doing in my
one hour of course you have to see if it
ties in hate is this go into that or I
want to just try this I want to I want
to work on that it doesn't feel fresh
anymore I'll go back in and you know try
to work on it backwards or whatever yay
yeah but you know there's no need to
destroy in the cellar I want to but
what's you I mean it's a small room so
you go in there you hope you can kill
with the newer stuff or stuff that
you're you're tinkering with I guess
it's just a weird philosophy to hear
that like you wouldn't just always your
default would be I just want to crush
the room you do want to crush the room
but the reality is and I respect the
Comedy Cellar but it's when when stuff
works there I know it will work on the
road or I at least think it will screw
they're not my fans in the Comedy Cellar
they're not your fans in the coming
solar no you just go on I don't give a
[ __ ] they just show up for a show they
don't care who's in the lineup you don't
think I always thought that the Comedy
Cellar was known kind of as like the
mecca of East Coast comedy like if
you're of comedy fan and you're in New
York you definitely stop by meaning
they're not they're like hey Jim
Norton's on the bill let's go see Bert I
know you didn't it's not a headline show
that's on tickets to it yeah so they're
just going to see a show they know
comedians drop in they know Collins
there a lot or they know that there's
good comics and you want to kill but
guys that are just going up at the
cellar and doing the stuff they've been
doing on weekends for years on the roads
and what the [ __ ] are you doing you're
supposed to be working out here this is
where you [ __ ] you know my system
becomes an ego thing or just like I just
want the laughs yeah but I like to get
the last with what I want to do like if
I'm writing a new opening now I'm trying
new opening line
and I finally figured out the opening to
my our set that I'm happy with I wasn't
happy with what I was doing for the last
six months and now it feels [ __ ] good
because it just happened one night you
know you try to go up with an idea like
with dinner Trump's [ __ ] grabby I'm not
gonna do in the specialty that won't be
topical by the time a terrorism hmm but
it's fun just to go up and talk about it
and you see where it goes yeah
if it lands on something funny it lands
on something funny yeah and then you
find what's funny in the next night you
tried it it's [ __ ] awesome it's fresh
and its new all the time
that's the ort store yeah that's where
right right right yeah bats with all
those guys economy sure do the same
thing improv I do the improv I'm in LA
mostly and that's the same thing there
is it there's that type of it energy
it's like but when you get young kids or
you get those people to just do their
acts to get [ __ ] and they go up and
murder and you're like great fantastic
yeah but they're not actually building
anything no I don't think they may never
shoot an hour right you know today's you
got to kill them when you're at a
certain point like when you're coming up
but there's a lot of pressure to [ __ ]
do well cuz you're competing for spots
you know what I mean it's like you're
competing with Dave Attell for spots at
the Comedy Cellar so what are gonna do
go up there and bomb for your [ __ ]
you're doing it for six but you can't
you have to go up there and kill but
once you say that I'm because I think I
was always caught in between that like I
remember one time seeing a Tosh go up
and murder with all brand-new stuff like
figuring things out murder and I was
like [ __ ] man and we were hanging out I
was like oh this is probably of five
years ago six years ago maybe even more
no had a shell I did not have a TV scene
he have a show yes he did I was not on
TV yet and he was his intosh point I was
on and he said and I was like I got a we
were hanging out I was like I gotta
[ __ ] write more he's like no you just
need to get famous and then write more
he was like it's pointless to he's like
you just gotta kill every time you go up
I was like so [ __ ] caught in between
that of like what wins the point when
you start going I'm okay to just work on
new material versus I need to go up and
do well tonight it depends on what you
want
like I get very bored like I get [ __ ]
out of my mind boy with material I do
like it tries to be crazy so I
eventually want to working on new stuff
and that usually becomes the opening
because then I just go on on the road
and start doing it up front and then I
[ __ ] it's like I [ __ ] out them into
the old material the stuff that gets
squeezed out the back end of the hour
just doesn't make it to the special yeah
I think I was I was in
the place we're headed on an hour in a
while I've done it since 2009
and I was just backlogged with all this
[ __ ] stuff that I knew worked and I
just had no passion for stand-up so I
was like I don't know work on new stuff
so I gotta get rid of this stuff when I
did this hour now I'm working on all new
stuff and it's like you get excited
about stand-up again
half the [ __ ] stuff I started on this
tour I'm not doing any more really
heaven I'm not doing I didn't even I
didn't even pay attention to it Kelsey's
father said after like a watch thing
you're not doing a lot of the stuff you
were doing it so you just kid like look
[ __ ] bored of boring yeah yeah yeah
how guys do it I've said that a million
times I don't know how they do it
[ __ ] four years oh [ __ ] I like like I
don't know how I don't know how like a
hypnotist does it where he's got to do
the same thing every time like or like
uh I mean some people just go up there
and they'll it they're not doing
anything like they just want adulation
like it doesn't matter what it is right
it's not the art form it's I'll tell
them when you see like young comics who
murder who are good-looking dudes I go
don't let [ __ ] derail your talent
because there's a lot of guys that
literally the I would name and you go
wait what ever happened to them it's
just like they were in New York and they
were in LA and they just it was about
getting on stage doing the bits that
made women think they want to [ __ ] them
right yeah and then you're like I mean
I'd say names but it would be rude but
there are guys we both know that you're
like man you were funny as [ __ ] but all
you cared about was getting it same it's
the same with alcohol alcoholics guys
who just are like I'm only at the club
so I can get [ __ ] drunk right they
get drunk before they go onstage it just
becomes this exercise like I have my ten
minutes this is the ten minutes that
gets me late I'm gonna go up I'm gonna
do my ten minutes that way I can get
late yeah boy is that not been my
[ __ ] mo no I have done nothing but
self-destruct actually you haven't found
that magical ten minutes see I have not
oh my god no he's right if I talk to her
on tinder so I uh I watch some of your
stuff [ __ ] sickening pregnant flaws
Oh people wonder why Jim is doing
specials every year though he's so
prolific yeah cuz he's searching for
that ten minute I can definitely trying
to find something that makes somebody
want to [ __ ] me for free
here act is the antithesis of what does
not work that way right
and it's not because he's he's an artist
it's because he just hasn't figured out
what this happened to get out what I can
do to override my looks we should take a
break
Burt your special is gonna be November
11th right 11 11 to 10:00 p.m. on
Showtime that's gonna be very very
exciting and Burt sticking around Jim
Norton tickets are on sale I'm in Philly
this weekend and tickets are now on sale
for November 4th Friday at the Melrose
improv I'm just doing one set there I'll
be in Fort Lauderdale the 18th and 19th
and possibly the 17th and then December
2nd 3rd is Hartford Connecticut I'm
doing the funny bone tickets just went
on sale for that and you know all
warming up for the Skirball to shoot
December 17th it's very good painting is
that were you shooting your special yeah
I've been shot there and [ __ ]
probably almost a decade but it's such a
great room and in New York through his
veil ability was hard and that room is
amazing so [ __ ] you do you know who is
releasing it I do but I can't it's not
that I can't I'm not allowed to take the
contractually they have to announce it
believe me I'd love to it I've wanted to
be for a long time it's gonna be very
very exciting you born but I really left
myself open to a [ __ ] even a meaner
statement of NASA and don't forget to
follow the show off all forms of social
media at Jim and Sam show on Twitter
Facebook Instagram snapchat